but here's what's really freaky Jennifer
Zhang is a youtuber I'm not super
familiar with who she is but she's been
tweeting a lot about what's going on she
tweeted this image and she writes
presumably a translation urgent notice
all-county town and village departments
all government departments in all towns
and villages must continue to implement
the level 1 response measures resume all
previous disease prevent and control
measures and make sure nothing goes
wrong when leaders from province come to
make unannounced inspections this week
implement all control measures at all
communities especially old communities
for densely populated places such as
hotels markets liquor stores and parks
resume temperature taking and
registering mainly and then there's
April 13th she says mainly applied to
people from other places who Bay and
Wuhan in the meantime take control
measures in villages according to local
situations all the above measures must
be implemented within one hour
jin-tae county nor does it say of Henan
Province coronavirus an ammonia control
office I'm sorry she says she said sorry
should be who Bay Province so I don't
have a province
apparently she tweeted this out what is
this this is yesterday morning and
people are saying the gist of it
China's going on a lockdown again yeah
they just started talking in the news no
new deaths no new no new cases they're
leaving lockdown back in lockdown visit
you know what man I'll tell you what
III there's no evidence right now to
suggest this is a bio weapon at least
we're at Fox News is reporting that
China was trying to show that they could
keep up with the US and they made a big
mistake yep
so even now government the government
actors you know the general ever haven't
confirmed that okay I'll tell you what
man could you ask for a more perfect
biological agent for this country no you
could not know its exact I wanted to
clarify I am in no way suggesting I am
saying this is extremely fortuitous in
every way for them and it makes me
suspect I'd like to see this
investigated because now we know there's
a cover-up that's being reported by
multiple outlets but here's here's what
I was thinking if this virus was like
Ebola level it'd be shut down in two
seconds you do it you you you if you
wanted something to be truly effective
at hurting people you'd want an airborne
virus you'd want a two week to week
incubation period and you'd want a
decently low mortality rate enough to
[ __ ] the country and panic and fear
to shut down naval vessels and weaken
your enemy yeah but at the same time
they admit they want to be better than
us they want to prove that they can
handle things better than Americans can
so this if if it did get out and that
you know this there was Americans that
were like they have of this lab that
were we should be worried about and
they're like no no no we could we can do
this we can handle it and then it gets
out and they're like oh man don't tell
anybody that it got out like let's try
to you know put a cap on this and then
it blows up and now it's worldwide
pandemic you know there I can see the
argument that they have they just
fumbled this in the worst way possible
you know and that that it might not be
any sort of act right right
I actually think the Fox News story
makes the most sense yeah and that's why
I'm not surprised by I'm surprised to
Bret Baier reporting it because I didn't
think we'd get hard confirmation like
this yeah but what you just said I I the
I really don't think they would try to
[ __ ] their own economy exactly I do
think they're bumbling morons who
slipped on a banana peel and dropped a
glass vial and went oh no oh yeah and
then it got out yeah that makes that it
makes way more sense like that you know
as much as some people have tried to say
that because of the trade war and
because you know China's economy has
been seriously hurting yeah that this
was their act of aggression I don't know
I I think it would have been way worse I
know I don't I don't I think it would
have been worse if they if they if it
was really them trying to hurt us how
could it be worse I mean we have those
reports from the Department of Justice
they've been smuggling in SARS virus
right to America so if it originated
Wuhan we have all these you know the
travel logs of like how it spread from
Wuhan and it's very clear from there if
they if they wanted to really hurt us
they would have dropped it in New York
City Kansas in - sure wherever yeah in
the
middle of in the middle of the country
so that it spread from here and then it
really didn't do that you're right
that's a good point because they've
tried claiming that it originated in the
US mm-hmm yeah that's what one of the
Chinese officials has said I think it
wasn't make any sense
of course right if China really wanted
to win they would have made it exactly
yeah so we so for those that didn't see
that story either Yahoo News and other
outs have reported that over the past
several years Chinese scientists were
smug illicitly bringing in viruses yes
some people we got caught with it yeah
lied about it until they were like well
what's his file oh well now that you
found that vial actually it's this set
it's the SARS virus yeah what I think we
got ourselves a case of Three Stooges
syndrome yeah maybe these China going
will slip in and then shattering the
vial and going yeah for real that's
that's that's that's what it is
yeah so I mean I'm it's not surprising
that what Fox News is reporting I think
most of us expected this yeah but I want
to entertain another possibility or not
maybe not a possibility but I want to
highlight this article you know China is
harvesting organs I pulled this up just
because I want to show you that these
people are our twist like their culture
their government whatever want to call
it yeah has anything to with race it has
to do with a group of people that are
harvesting organs yeah so I got to
wonder what they're doing and I also got
to wonder why I should trust them but
again I do think Fox News is reporting
really does make the most sense they're
bumbling morons yeah as much as I think
they would intentionally do really
really messed-up stuff I think more so
there's this common problem we see with
communism Chernobyl you know they they
they get an idea they rush forward and
then just like it's like it almost
reminds me of someone doing a jigsaw
puzzle okay and they find a piece that
looks like it could fit it doesn't so
they just start pounding on the table
that's that's how I kind of described
how how these communists becoming these
countries try and implement these ideas
yeah you know like Chernobyl it's like
you can see it's a nuclear reactor we
kind of understand how to work and then
we blows up and sprays radioactive you
know carbon or whatever in the
atmosphere or like China being like
we're gonna make a bio lab and then they
just are slamming the table to make it
fit and then
breach like they're nasty what they're
doing with with people china forcefully
harvesting organs it's messed up I
wonder though man it's really messed up
what do we do if this story is true I
mean what do you mean if do we not know
for certain that they're doing this okay
so what do we do now that we know this
story it's true so it's it's officially
true now it's like it's not that I like
didn't believe it you know how do we
spend some what horses what more could
we have to confirm this that's the
challenge right so I know YouTube's
already gonna gonna smack it smack us in
the face for even talking about it
they're gonna de rank this segment will
be demonetized 100% they're gonna say
how dare you say it yeah well you got
multiple outs the Washington Post you
got a professor from Rutgers you had Fox
News Brett Bayer they're all saying it
you know what else do we need to say
this is confirmed cuz I'll tell you what
I know there's gonna be a lot of people
reluctant to say it is even part of me
I'm like oh man do we say it but here's
the thing a University in China released
a paper saying they were experimenting
on bats some guy got bit some guy got
peed on you know and he had a quarantine
himself they think that was the probable
source you then at the Washington Post
saying we need to talk about this the
National Review conservative paper
saying let's talk about this the all
roads leading back to the lab and now
Brett Bay are saying sources familiar
with the reactions are saying this and
the AP coming out saying China withheld
the information and the World Health
Organization lied to us
what more does anyone need to say boom
there it is yeah yeah right and it's not
it's not to say whether it was it was
malicious or not because that's
irrelevant for this for them all to seem
it is true no it was malicious well
that's not what they're saying it
absolutely things it originated from oh
no no no no no no them lying for six
days yes that's malicious sure
absolutely
right but was it you was that
intentional spread right was that them
bumbling and going what do we do for six
days I'm a good point or was it like
them going all right let's let's let the
brew on it I actually agree at you make
a good point I think the six days of
doing nothing was Three Stooges syndrome
yeah I think they were running around in
circles popping each other on that going
there someone give me an answer someone
give me an answer right now six days
later
alright let's just tell the world yeah
they know their apologies - stupid -
yeah they know what to do yeah it was
about an answer it was like Xi Jinping
is going like you over there give me a
report and then he like runs over and
slams into like a low-hanging tree
branch or something it falls down yeah
and then the other one then it's like
you know it's just bumbling around like
morons well you know that they have
mal-intent like I mentioned with those
camps there they're doing oh yeah but
yeah I look I think even if they were
they were bumbling around like Stooges
which it really does seem like they were
at least that's what the evidence you
know suggests now they could have told
us exactly but that's you know what I
gotta be fair it being a [ __ ] I think
you would be predisposed to not ask for
help you know I mean like they think
they're all tough their whole thing is
to try to be better than us or better
than everyone you know it's like so
they're like they're trying to save face
as much as possible and now it's now
it's crumbling and what's worse is it's
crumbling in there their citizens are
starting to get upset yeah you know
their citizens are starting to like
group up and band together because
they're sick of this also thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you